hey guys i want to do a little update on
blender it's on
version 2.92 and i've been doing this
video editing series in case you don't
know i'll leave a link down below to the
latest one
the whole series if you want to watch
all that or whatever but video editing
with blender it's a real thing
it works okay sometimes and there's been
some improvements that haven't really
been
addressed so it's kind of weird
like let me uh let me just go to their
site here
alright so uh release notes on 2.92
here we go there we go
quick search for video there's now theme
alternate row colors in the video
sequencer i couldn't figure out how to
do this but if you click on it you can
see where they
made the changes just looks like there's
no this is just like a visual change so
i don't think there's a whole lot to
actually
uh go off of on this like there's no
editorial changes so that's the only
thing they mentioned but in the video
they
like uh
the the new features here in less than
five minutes and here they mention
that they've been working on the video
editor
to improve it and that's it so i have
noticed a few things
so i think this is just kind of flying
under the radar we're going to do a
little test today
and see if we can just observe these new
changes and see how it goes
so we're going to yep just launch
blender of course uh if you want to
follow along you do have to be
on the latest version 2.92
and we're just going to go up here click
the button go to video editing
and we're to our video editing thing so
i'm just going to bring in
a video just a random league of legends
ones pretty long
and we're going to bring in some audio
because previously
there was this bug where
when you duplicated audio it would like
scream at you and
extremely loud i don't know it was weird
it would just
it just had a really big problem with
duplicating
audio so we're going to test and see if
it still does that in this latest
version there was no mention of it that
i could tell
so i'm going to just bring in some audio
and i'm just going to extend this out
hit page up down here copy this
in frame there go back here press home
now i don't expect you to follow along
most of the stuff i'm doing i kind of
explained in the other
tutorials so i'm just really just a
quick test here
and display the waveform on that um i'm
gonna press
t go to this little slight well
now let's just just make a few random
cuts here
um just uh just to kind of get some
things buffered in because that's
uh that's generally how like i'm working
when
i have this audio bug so i just kind of
want to replicate that a little bit
all right so we'll just move some things
around maybe
let me go in here
okay so in theory
let's i'm gonna mute this audio and just
do
i don't know how loud this is gonna be i
just don't want to suddenly blare it
okay so we're going to play this
right here and see what it does
[Music]
it seems fine now if we do a copy paste
it over here
and now let's play it over here so what
used to happen when you did this when
you just did like
copy and paste because you wanted two
different spots is it would just like
triple buffer loudness scream
in your ears so loud for no particular
reason
so let's see if it still does that
okay i need the league of legends
doesn't seem to be doing it okay that's
good let's uh make another copy over
here
[Music]
so as far as i can tell this bug is
fixed
of this whole copy audio and it blaring
in your ears for no particular reason
it seems to actually be working properly
now now you might have noticed that like
this sequencer just seems faster
so i believe they've done some kind of
memory improvement i don't know i still
they didn't seem to mention any patch
notes
but there does seem to be some
improvements behind the scenes
just wanted to point that out do a
little live quick test here
and kind of confirm um now i i'd have to
see like the change log or code to
100 confirm but i can say
it seems like it's fixed so
uh i'm going to do a little digging in
and see if i can find out
if there's there's more to it or if
there's any
any change log that i missed about this
sequencer being
improved maybe in 2.91 i didn't cover
anything in 2.91
let's go back do the 2.91 release notes
see what kind of video stuff they
mentioned
faster video encoding decoding so this
is probably
where the sequencer was improved
actually 2.91
improved performance especially
noticeable when viewing
results and repeated image cool
smoothness of uvs can be okay
so yeah these two are big that's
probably where we're seeing the
improvements actually from last version
which i didn't cover it and really test
um let's see anything else
let's prove some distortion and some
uh ffmpeg libraries now supported
oh okay vectorization yeah i'd have to
dig into this know exactly what that
means but it appears
that uh it's probably the sequential
sequencer improvements that are
making the big changes all right
well that's it just wanted to point out
that blender
video editing is getting better tested
live it seems to be
a lot better i don't use it quite as
much for video editing just because i've
kind of moved to davinci resolve
recently but i still do occasionally use
this it works great as a video editor
and people still seem to ask even though
i cover in every video
the same questions which i answer in
almost every video so i'm not going to
get into that but
thanks for watching let me know if you
have any questions down below
and i'll try to get to them unless
they're a repeat of stuff we've answered
many times already
all right see you guys in the next one
peace out